I think of anything you didn't realize
that you just touched my Germans are so
bad at comedy even the language they
tried to use to softball it like we need
to find a way to sell this that's less
harsh final absolution so glad to have
this next guest on she's been on the
program before but it was before we had
the whole ladder with Crowder videocast
stuff going on it was just her s triol
so you can see some of her fantastic
work they have an incredible amount of
signatures in this petition to defund
Planned Parenthood at Planned Parenthood
exposed calm Lela Rose thank you for
being on hi Steven thing for having me
good to see you good to see you for
those listening terrestrially she's
wearing a lovely red dress do you just
hang around the house like this all the
time or do you did you of course always
I wake up I wake up wearing a red dress
yeah just kidding I've never seen you
not look that way at all these functions
I just picture you being born like
coming out with full attire makeup
walking walking run like right it's not
like that in the morning I am joking
yeah well I can imagine it takes it
takes a lot of work to make this look
marginal so Lila obviously big in the
news right now I'm it's been going away
at Abby Johnson on firstly now you do
live-action films do you have any direct
involvement with center for medical
progress that's doing these current
stings so this was totally David who's a
good friend of mine actually the
execution was totally his I have known
David for years that he's worked with me
before for years out live action so I'm
pretty familiar with David okay good
well because these things are coming out
right now and it's obviously I mean
you've done this for a long time with
live action and why do you think it is
now that these are getting so much
traction because I remember so many
things that you've done to our
incredibly horrifying do you think it's
just that the country is tipping one
direction and it's it's sort of
resonating because these things are
catching on like wildfire do you think
it's just that it's so horrifying it has
to be acknowledged I think it's probably
through briefings videos directly speak
to the humanity of a child we hear about
the heart the lung the liver we hear
about heart still beating when the child
is born intact we know that this is a
child it's unmistakable undeniable when
you hear about planned parent and
abortionist talking about how they're
going to sell the parts of the babies
that they've just killed so that
really cuts to the core I think two
other things though is second involve
people across the country there's been a
barrage of this now for over a dozen
years and drip drip drip more and more
people over time are hearing so this is
kind of like a straw that could break
the camel's back it could be the final
nail in the coffin it depends on how
much we're willing to stand up for
justice and for the rights of these
children and then finally I think that
new media has a huge role to play here
new media which is now becoming the
media and the power of social media to
get messages out that the mainstream
media otherwise would censor right
here's one thing that I think is pretty
telling I'll be honest I don't know that
this will change a whole lot as far as
the media I wish it would but here's why
because I think at one point the media
tried to sort of put out this air of
being on bias of what we're delivering
the news I think now they're so far in
they're going you know what yet we're
carrying the heavy water for Planned
Parenthood we're in the tank for them
and they don't really care that much I
don't think Katie Couric is going to
come out or someone like it you know
Brian Williams way back into the day I
don't think they would come out
acknowledge these videos and say all
right we were wrong this is a horrible
organization it needs to be defunded I
think we're past the point where they'll
defend it but I think the real value
here is the court of public opinion
because you're not going to reach the
elites who already are so deeply
entrenched but I think a lot of
Americans who genuinely bought into the
myth that Planned Parenthood provide
women's health and mammograms are having
their eyes open do you think that's an
accurate read or my off-base no I think
you're totally right you're right on
Stephen because Katie Couric and you
know the big three mainstream EDS CBS
ABC NBC they're dying breeds and they
gave I think it was there was a study
done and they gave over ninety nine
percent more coverage to Cecil the lion
than they gave to the fact that in
America in our own neighborhoods we're
butchering babies and selling their
parts and allowing abortion facilities
at Planned Parenthood to do this so I
think that they are a dying breed and I
think that they're not not going to
admit they're wrong and they're going to
go down with that sinking ship and I
feel sorry for a lot of folks in
mainstream media who are just letting
this story pass them by and they refuse
to have the basic intellectual honesty
and I think journalistic integrity to
actually report on things
that impact people across the country
every day yeah you know I guess I don't
really have a problem with that anymore
as long as they're honest about it I've
always assumed that everybody has a bias
that's always been me I'd be left be
right just don't lie to me about it you
know um I don't have a problem with
someone like a Bill Maher I don't I
don't particularly like him I don't hate
him but he's honest about it I don't
really have a problem with the Rachel
Maddow even though I think she's wrong
on virtually every issue because you
know where she's coming from I have a
problem with the soft bias you know the
big bias here you just hit the nail on
the head when you mentioned it and a lot
of people watching this won't even
really recognize what was being said
there it's not someone coming out
necessarily defending Planned Parenthood
it's that so many in nightly news won't
even address this it's all over social
media but they won't even address it on
nightly news is that disparity you think
growing even more in like a post
Breitbart world where I mean for example
Shaun King right now is all over fake
black eye which is hilarious either this
story this story isn't funny but nowhere
on the news on television
you think that's growing that gap is
going to be even wider yeah the gap is
growing and I have a problem with that I
have a problem with the fact that people
even like Jimmy Kimmel can get on on his
show and with you know millions people
watching and cry over the death of a
lion a continent away that a lot of
folks in the country didn't even have
the same emotional reaction for well
this was tragic meanwhile hey there's
not a single tear shed for the millions
of babies slaughtered in America and
there's their parts so not only not a
tear shed but just like you're saying
Steven they're not even talking about it
I mean they're sticking their heads in
the sand so it's not even that they're
defending Planned Parenthood although
when they do even mention Planned
Parenthood they try to do it in a
positive way I mean the Washington Post
actually changed its headlines away from
Planned Parenthood selling body parts to
plan parent it's supporting fetal tissue
research so there's all of that bias
happening but I think the worst thing
that's happened is that they don't talk
about it and they don't talk about it
because basically the only thing to say
is what's being exposed which is that
they're selling the parts of babies and
they're killing and butchering them in
their facilities and to even begin to
address it they would have to say some
of the truth and they don't want to tell
the truth about this right yeah I think
it's pretty rough and
in what I find so fascinating in these
videos right now is the people involved
use the word babies and heads you know
they go well and they use some technical
terminology and they go ahead baby had
or they go you know it'll do well baby
likes you know when they're talking
about it amongst themselves and they
don't realize the cameras are rolling
this is the terminology they use and it
goes to show the power of language right
that it's there's a proactive war that
uses language that weaponize this
language in the biggest takeaway for me
obviously it was horrendous I have to
look away at some of these videos
honestly I'm watching it's like like a
horror film like when I was a kid now
it's watching leprechaun I can't watch
the whole thing but that amongst their
inner circle they use the language that
they claim is inaccurate that to me is
pivotal yeah I mean did you ever have
that when you did a lot of the the
undercover work as well it seems like
that's sort of a development now we're
going to adds a baby well I think that
the abortion is you're right they use
the terminology they call it a baby we
found undercover investigators at
abortion clinics across the country and
the abortionist say it's a baby and they
even talk about killing the baby I mean
they're willing to speak speak bluntly
and can't callously about chopping the
baby up and tearing the baby apart is
selling the baby's body parts but the
media won't even use those same
terminology all of a sudden it becomes a
fetus or tissue or the products of a
pregnancy and it's just I mean it's it's
classic textbook Orwell Orwellian speak
when you want to dehumanize a group of
people you don't call them people when
you want to shut off the dignity of
people that you don't want to respect
you try to marginalize them and
dehumanize them in the way you even talk
about them I mean in Nazi Germany they
called exterminating the Jews the Jewish
Question or the Jewish solution to the
Jewish problem they didn't even want to
talk about of course people and ovens
and and the slaughter of those in the
concentration camps they're not going to
in any who I use any of that language
they're going to talk about the final
solution that was the language that was
used and right now we have a final
solution that's being enacted in America
and the purveyors of it the folks
pushing it Planned Parenthood had their
own set of euphemisms that they use and
that's why it's so important to break
those down and get
truth in front of people I think of
anything you didn't realize that you
just touched on why Germans are so bad
at comedy even the language they tried
to use to softball to like we need to
find a way to sell this that's less
harsh final absolution this this quest
maybe if we add question mark there just
like they didn't even sell it well even
at that point everyone knew oh this is
gonna be bad and then they get to
lecture us now even on things like
abortion they get to talk to us about
how progressive they are right because
the United States even though we have so
many abortions they're still as a public
opinion that that it is morally wrong I
think there's a separation between the
two there I want to get into one point
though here so to play devil's advocate
leftists will say and I've seen them say
it's perfectly legal
selling tissue like this so once you
remove the emotional part of the
equation and you think that it's a baby
this is legal is that true what are the
case yeah okay why come on yeah totally
so tell me why it's not there is
actually five different federal laws and
regulatory regulations that are being
violated and the top three because it
could take forever to explain all of
them but the top three is that Planned
Parenthood is selling and profiting from
baby parts and it's proved by the
conversations you hear from top
abortionist in these videos it's proved
by the fact that the companies that they
do business with like stem express in
California actually markets in public
advertisements that are now open to the
public on the Center for medical
progress website that there's financial
benefits and improvements for the clinic
so they talk about doing better than
breaking even it's clear that profit is
happening number two they talk and admit
to manipulating the abortion procedure
at Planned Parenthood when they're
delivering these babies and and trying
to sell their parts so that they deliver
for the baby intact so they have a
better better you know opportunity to
harvest the heart and the lungs and the
liver and that's against federal statute
to manipulate the abortion procedure and
the third major one is partial birth
abortion in fact their top two abortion
as their director of medical services
dr. Deborah Nicola in the first video
explains how she delivers the baby
breech that means she delivers the baby
the feet first the but the the torso in
order to ultimately have basically a
live specimen
once the baby's born so that it's fully
intact and it's easier to harvest the
the parts that's partial birth abortion
which is at West which is in federally
banned so those are just three examples
of federal statutes being broken except
that our president was a big fan of that
when he was in Illinois so um you know
listen and President Clinton this is
true they can always call in for a favor
upstairs so there we go okay its
indefensible legally it's obviously
indefensible morally you know we're
going to have you on for another segment
but I'm seeing now we have to make room
for my lowly innopolis to come in so
you're you do a lot of great work how
many petitions signatures do you have
your Etta I want to get the site right
Planned Parenthood exposed is it comm
org we have Planned Parenthood exposed
calm and there's over 200,000 Sinese
please add your name we're not trying to
work with other groups behind the scenes
to ultimately add a lot of these names
together to get a million signatures so
your name does count plan period expose
calm add your name and we want to work
to fight to defund Planned Parenthood
and we need you to be involved in that
so science and the petition they're
enjoying the fight let me ask you this
if it doesn't get defunded right let's
say it doesn't happen someone signs a
petition is there anything else anyone
can do I do know that a lot of people
including you know producer Jared here
you feel somewhat helpless because it's
this gargantuan sort of organization is
there anything else anyone can do if
they want to go out you know and I'll
save babies to put it bluntly three
things educate yourself make sure you
know the facts about what's happening
watch the videos learn more about
abortion in America number two be bold
share with friends don't be afraid to
talk about this be fearless this is an
incredible human rights crisis we all
need to get involved and then number
three get involved in pro-life work in
your community praying outside abortion
clinics with your church with your
school get involved with the pro-life
right to life through politically get
involved and fight for the rights for
the of these children and a better
America for families yes or if it
doesn't float your boat just cry for a
lion go out there and protest what
contributes to I don't know 50 percent
of their GDP because everyone needs a
cause and you can choose human life or
soulless man-eating killers lions killed
249 people last year in that you can cry
for both of them we can cry for both of
them right if we don't
for children while we cry for lions
something is seriously wrong I got you
we're gonna have to let you go I I will
cry for the gazelles though not so much
the Lions Lila Rose Planned Parenthood
exposed calm stay tuned for more my
Lully innopolis coming right up how you
subscribe by clicking my face or watch
one of these videos next to me because
hey what do they want to subscribe again